we've got some breaking news this
morning
[Music]
NBC a new far-right Behavior has just
dropped and that behavior is
exercise
that can't be right MSNBC writes quote
the far rights obsession with Fitness is
going digital now Libs had already
warned us about certain other behaviors
that are markers of far white far right
that's the exact same thing white
supremacist Neo-Nazi extremism behaviors
such as
um working hard
uh being on time and speaking English
when the libs announced those three
indicators of far-right behavior I've
got to admit I got a little bit worried
now however I feel much better I am in
no danger of radicalization or far-right
extremism because if working out is
right wing baby I am a regular Bernie
Sanders